je pensais que j'étais 30
ça s'est passé environ quatre mois après
mon coming out comme lesbienne en mars
je me promenais beaucoup sur internet
sur des sites spécialisés dans les
questions de diversité sexualité et de
genre j'ai commencé à me questionner sur
mon genre ce jeune fille en or
entrée 2 qui suis-je bon je vais jeter
pas les samoa la fille a pu comme la
[ __ ] borie mais je peux non plus la
plus féminine non je peux la la fille
qui semait du mes copies qui se
promènent avec des talons pis toolkit
j'ai quand sa pomme sentir comme une
fille pendant les vacances d'été et je
m'étais beaucoup questionné jusqu'à ce
que j'arrive à la conclusion que je me
sentais comme un coeur donc je devrais
en être un j'ai fait ma transition à
l'école au début de l'année scolaire
tout le monde commençait à bas prix d'un
long échange et de l as tu commencé à
consulter un spécialiste dans le domaine
j'avais peut-être vu deux ou trois fois
au total toujours été une personne
confiante mais pendant cette période de
temps mon estime de moi a baissé
beaucoup j'essaie de vivre selon
l'étiquette que je m'étais donné je
sortais à côté de moi même j'ai essayé
d'agir de façon plus masculine oublié
mon côté plus féminin m'oublier mois
s'est passé sur mon genre était obsédant
je pensais tout le temps le mois de mars
2018 arrive je suis parti une semaine il
à vic pour un échange étudiant toutes
les pensées sur mon genre ou disparus
quelques mois plus tard on part m'a
demandé où j'étais rendu dans tout ça et
je lui dis que j'ai ressorti juste
moi.com un genre houriez juste moi
j'ai réalisé au fond que je n'étais pas
trop là j'ai commencé à le dire à ma
famille à mes amis à majorité de bondy
qui ne m'avait jamais vraiment cru et
j'ai été rendu compte que au fond
j'étais une fille fiq et de se sentir
comme un garçon ça ne veut rien dire
pour moi mon estime de moi et mille fois
meilleur ainsi que ma santé mentale
j'ai réalisé qu'au final qui peut juste
lesbiennes ma famille mes amis proches
m'appellent de nouveau la rue
[Musique]